[Musique]
premier vidéo j'étais là c'est la
température
leurs 47 le belge s'offre au dessus
match très froid température mouvements
bizarres
[Musique]
ouais bon sport en fête vous avez votre
match comme ça il devrait aborder ces
questions à la fin qui a vidé son base
de vos allées attention ça tourne
[Musique]
c'est fait merci tacle en retard parce
que ça devient très dur en battant deux
surveillants non merci ça va bouger
merci d'être là d'echery merci à mes
débuts je vous laisserai plus à venir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'endors avec moins d'écart ouais
matin ou stocks à hauteur des tas de
briques au tarissement